These quick fingerless mitts offer
endless possibilities for being creative.
I knit this pair about 10 times
in my mind, considering all
the different variations I could use.
Thankfully, I still have lots of yarn
and can make another pair using more
of the ideas I've been considering.
Here's what I ended up deciding.
I knit a long piece of ribbing.
The entire arm is in one by one ribbon,
and it fits nice and snug.
The hand is plain stockinette.
I finished it with about one inch
of ribbing, and instead of messing
with binding off that ribbing,
I knit a few plain rows and bound off.
This rolled edge saved me from a tedious
Kitchener stitch bind-off,
and it's a nice decorative touch.
If you aren't familiar with this cast-on,
it just adds a strand in the tubular
edge that I can pull up.
I gathered up this edge and hit
it with a shot of steam to set it.
This keeps the cast
on edge from flaring out.
Following my pattern,
I knit in ribbing to the start
of the thumb opening, and then
I placed markers on each side.
I was done with my ribbing,
so I transferred all
of the stitches to the main bed.
I knit to the end of the thumb opening
and placed another set of markers.
Now this is designed as a fast project,
so there isn't a thumb and no
messing around with the thumb gore.
Again, following my pattern,
I finished the hand in stockinette.
I transferred the stitches back down
to the ribber, switched out
the connecting arm, and raised my ribber.
I knit one inch in ribbing.
Now, one more time,
I transferred the stitches back
to the main bed and dropped the ribber,
switching the connecting arms
and just knit a few rows.
Binding off loosely here will allow
my mitten to stretch over my fingers,
but the one inch of ribbing
will keep it snug.
Seaming with this yarn that has very
little twist was a bit of a challenge.
It wanted to fray and break.
I was reminded of a suggestion years ago
from a very experienced knitter that I
could use a different yarn for my seam,
something that doesn't fray or break.
Done neatly, no one will ever
know that I used a different yarn to seam.
With all this yarn left,
I can't wait to start another pair.
They're so soft and comfy and nice
and warm for this cold weather
here in Southern California.